allez
salut tout le monde ça arrive dans le
chat de salut Florian ça lui Perly salut
Paul et on accueille déjà on dit bonjour
à On dit bonjour à Manu et un habitué
bonjour Manu ça va ce soir bonjour pour
toi oui ça va oui c'est bonjour pour moi
bonsoir pour vous
et ça lui constant deuxième fois hier
Thunders
à tous bonsoir à tous en espérant avoir
un meilleur micro que la dernière fois
en tout cas moins de problèmes audio que
la dernière fois mais au très heureux
d'être là ce soir est-ce que est-ce que
tu stresses toujours autant est-ce que
ça monte est-ce que tu es rassuré parce
que tu entends
là on est plus dans la patience que dans
le stress en fait on est on est là on a
envie que on a envie d'être le soir de
la DRAF là on a envie de voir ce que ça
me prestine ou concoct on est on va dire
les dernières rumeurs ne tendent à être
plutôt rassuré
et on accueille Jocelyn du un des
membres de l'équipe 50 nuances de NBA
Jocelyn
salut salut les gars
merci d'être à vous bah ouais merci
merci beaucoup de d'être là en plus on
entend même pas la fête de la musique à
côté de chez toi donc normalement j'ai
mes écouteurs ça devrait pas être trop
mal
les reprises de Johnny à gogo de Johnny
c'est ambitieux
c'est la foire aux questions donc comme
toute bonne foire aux questions il faut
une fois donc là c'était déjà à voir
pour commencer il faut des questions
donc c'est toi c'est toi qui va nous
donner la première question et Manu et
moi manu a plus regardé mais moi j'ai
regardé un petit peu on va essayer de
répondre à attends attends
il y a un nouvel invité
Romain Leroy en direct de sa cave ça va
tu nous diras tu nous diras quand ça
sera bon romain
on va je t'entends pas moi je t'entends
pas on va on va prendre en face tentant
de loin très très loin on va prendre la
question de Jocelyn
on est loin
alors moi ma première question c'était
autour de
du traitement autour de Kigan Murray
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un gros
Delta autour de la vision que les médias
ont de ce joueur je vois pas mal de
rumeurs qui le prévoit en 4 que ce soit
pour les Kings ou pour une franchise qui
voudrait très up mais je l'ai aussi par
exemple dans votre draft qui est sorti
tout à l'heure je le vois en 12 je crois
et j'avoue que moi avec mes
connaissances qui sont peut-être un peu
moindres si j'avais dû faire une moque
je l'aurais mis aussi dans ces eaux là
top 10 bordure top 10 fin de loterie et
du coup je voulais savoir votre avis
pourquoi aussi gros Delta sur la vision
de ce genre alors il y a notre avis et
il y a
il y a la vie des franchises qui est pas
le même déjà donc ça ça
dépend mais moi alors c'est moi qui ai
fait j'assume avec mes petits doigts
musclés cette mob grave qui n'est pas
forcément réaliste
dans le sens où sans doute que Kylian me
reste reparti une fois une fois le petit
bout j'ai vu ça mais
oui c'était chez toi
Manu qu'est-ce qu'on dit qui vient de
Murray est-ce que est-ce que finalement
on rate quelque chose avec qui gagne
Murray tout le monde le mec 4 5 6 est-ce
que c'est et nous on est plutôt dans le
10 15 20 quoi
quelque chose je sais pas nous on n'a
pas accès au psychologique je pense que
là ça peut avoir un rôle assez important
dans la décision après je pense que le
fait qu'il est monté comme ça c'est par
rapport à sa progression qui est
indéniable sur ces deux saisons
moi ce qui me bloque plus c'est surtout
son âge 22 ans donc c'est un Sopho mort
quand à l'âge d'un senior
donc en termes de progression selon moi
ça veut dire que c'est assez limité et
progressera toujours mais il progresse
pas il progressera pas autant qu'un
Paolo bankiro par exemple qui a 19 ans
c'est
plus sur ça après en terme de de jeux
aussi je pense qu'il a pas le
rendu dans dans un joueur top 5 tout
simplement il fait pas des choses
exceptionnelles il a pas le truc Elite
pour moi mais ça ça reste un bon joueur
de 2-03 serait de fort capable de
défendre sur plusieurs positions de de
très très bien tirer de de voilà donc je
pense un peu j'ai un peu la même
réflexion qu'on avait sur
sur Ali Burton sur lui c'est un joueur
qui va être bon dans une équipe
Contenders
du coup c'est on s'est trompé sur sur
lui mais du coup je le vois plus dans
une équipe type
[Musique]
qui a besoin de production tu as besoin
de production un peu à la dans le top 10
il y a du il y a du Portland qui veut
construire rapidement il y a du Pélican
ce qui veut ouais voilà je le vois plus
dans ce genre d'équipe là que le Sunder
par exemple ou Houston qui l'objectif
principal n'est pas forcément de gagner
un titre ni de ni d'être en pleurs
l'année prochaine c'est de viser le top
5 de la draft qui va être incroyable
l'année prochaine donc je le vois plus
dans une équipe comme ça donc je le
baisse automatiquement alors si romain a
un son
[Rires]
constante toi je sais que tu as regardé
un peu les prospects toi tu dis en 12 ça
va mais tu aimerais pas que quand tu
aimerais pas citer le site ton équipe
choisissait en 6 tu aimerais pas que ça
soit qui viennent me répondre NON NON
pour les mêmes raisons qui a énoncé Manu
je trouve que le prospect on le
sous-estime un petit peu en termes de
qualité j'ai eu beaucoup de gens faire
une analogie entre Killian Murray
obitopin par exemple dans ce profil de
joueurs un peu plus âgés qui est
sélectionné trop pour moi c'est un peu
faire offense à qui gagnerait parce que
je trouve que c'est un vrai bon joueur
par contre oui effectivement si pas en 4
Hawkings comme ça a l'air d'être le cas
ou même si par ne serait-ce que top 5 ou
top 6 c'est pas forcément un joueur que
moi je privilégie parce que je préfère
me projeter sur des joueurs qui ont un
peu plus de talent et je suis pas
convaincu effectivement qui gagnerait
possède un potentiel plus élevé que je
sais pas un LG green un durée ou même un
Dyson Daniel je Bénédicte
dans une équipe qui n'a pas besoin d'un
joueur avec un extraordinaire potentiel
par exemple comme les pêches je pense
qu'en 8 Opel il ferait beaucoup de bien
mais pour ce qui est une équipe de
reconstruction je sais pas vers ce genre
de profil pour faire lequel je ne dirai
mon personnellement
[Musique]
soit nécessairement transposable en NBA
donc ouais pour moi quand je vois c'est
la question que je me pose en fait à
laquelle j'ai pas la réponse je vois
beaucoup de prospects qu'on critique
parce qu'ils sont un petit peu flemmard
en défense ou qui sont pas forcément
concernés au vol personnellement c'est
pas quelque chose que j'ai envie de leur
mettre de manière négative pour moi
c'est un par exemple pour un LG Griffin
c'est quelque chose qui va se régler
très rapidement une fois qu'il va
arriver dans une franchise je voudrais
bien avoir votre avis sur le fait que
selon moi on accorde trop de crédit aux
mauvaises performances défensives des
fraîchement Romain Leroy
le problème c'est que très souvent
j'espère qu'il y a pas d'écho
on est bon parfait je suis obligé de
déco je m'entends j'ai pas sûr étant
radio très souvent en fait
d'une part les joueurs sont jeunes et
habitués à jouer dans des contextes
défensifs très précis puisque la NCIS
reste malgré tout une unique de coach
quoi qu'on en dise et moi l'expérience
que j'ai très souvent des joueurs Rocky
qu'on a pu récupérer en Europe mais si
croyez-moi tu leur apprends à défendre
donc c'est à dire que ce qui va être
intéressant ça va plus être tout ce qui
va être sur les intangibles sur
l'attitude sur le ce qui va montrer
comme détermination comme comme on vit
de défendre plutôt que l'évaluation à
proprement parler dans le système Lyoko
qui correspond qui correspond pas
exemple extrême
comment tu veux évaluer défensivement un
joueur assez accuse
qui fait énormément de zones
pratiquez sûrement dimanche matin ou à
la grande époque des paniers pour Alex
mais
cette partie des choses moi je vais
avoir tendance à regarder comment se
comporte le joueur individuellement
comme on est dans le respect des
consignes il y a le playmaking défensif
que tu peux évaluer un petit peu aussi
mais aujourd'hui les cycles sont
tellement courts à la fac
que finalement les joueurs
doivent avoir une rentabilité tout de
suite pour être dans le kebab
les joueurs les plus intéressants
défensivement aujourd'hui qui a sur la
projection premier tour c'est les mecs
qui sont au moins au moins sauf morts
voire junior et qui ont déjà un impact
tout à fait tout à fait
mais tu parles de l'attitude constante
disait à raison que souvent on dit
machin il a pas trop envie de défendre
et est-ce que ça ça peut pas être excusé
par le volume offensif parce qu'il y a
des il y a des tops je parle des tops
prospects
du top 5 6 ils vont pas être
100% engagé enfin c'est rare en tout cas
soit 100% engagé en défense tout le
temps sur leur année fraîchement et
pourtant forcément dire qu'ils vont
devenir des mauvais défenseurs non mais
est-ce que tu as demandé à Paulo
bancaire au de ce de plonger sur les
ballons de mettre des points et
d'apporter du playmaking il peut faire
les deux mecs il peut faire les deux
mais à un moment l'autre les mecs se
cale aussi souvent dans le rôle qu'on va
leur donner ou dans le rôle dans lequel
ils veulent se projeter pour après
Manu Manu est-ce qu'il y a des prospects
parmi le gratin de cette année que tu
excuses un petit peu en défense constant
à parler des digrifting Paolo banquero
pour le coup dans cette cuvée on n'a pas
trop de
dire qu'il y avait des fainéants en
défense ouais effectivement les
prospects de view que ça revient souvent
et bon chez Eden chat
moi je vais les excuser s'ils apportent
énormément offensivement c'est un peu ce
que ce que disait romain s'ils ont un
rôle offensif plein je vais les excuser
perdre un peu en lucidité défensivement
en fait puisqu'ils vont me rapporter des
points il me rapporter peut-être des
victoires grâce à ça donc je suis pas je
suis pas trop inquiet après du doute
c'est assez compliqué parce que c'est
des défenses assez bizarres qui qui nous
fait coacher tout le temps qui maîtrise
pas trop enfin je sais pas trop ce qu'il
fait en fait c'est c'est pas
on arrive toujours à cette phrase de
Churchill que je ressort tout le temps
si l'adversaire on ne sait pas ce qu'on
fait l'adversaire peut pas savoir
beaucoup pratiqué cette année
absolument une question sur Paolo
bancaireo ça dépend si vous italianisez
dans le chat et ce qui peut devenir un
poste 5 de playoff intéressant romain
qu'est-ce que tu en penses est-ce que on
a vu dans certaines équipes
des on a vu des lin-up avec des joueurs
je sais pas plus petit mais au moins de
la taille de Paolo goncero je veux jouer
simple surtout que sur le j'ai noté ça
sur le dernier combat il était modifié à
le modifier pardon mesurer à deux 900
chaussures
le problème c'est que si tu le prends
sur un poste 5 de playoff c'est à dire
que tu pars sur du Small Ball
comme 5 exclusifs avec du temps de jeu
est-ce que tu te prives pas de ce qui
peut faire avantage ça peut vraiment
vraiment passer donc on gagne sur du
passing game mais est-ce que est-ce que
lui c'est pas comme pas la sécurité
sociale en quatre quand même je pense
que ça peut physiquement ça peut il y a
pas de souci mais
[Musique]
peut-être des actions quand même c'est
ce qui m'inquiète prendre un avantage
sur un matchup particulier voilà un
adversaire pour sortir faire sortir un 5
adverse par exemple le forcer
dans ce sens là après il y a une vraie
capacité à aller chercher les fautes
donc c'est intéressant mais moi je le
vois plus 4
capable de tenir un peu la balle et de
porter un peu la balle donc quatre très
moderne donc on va dire un trois et demi
plus qu'un 4 pure ou alors un cas très
moderne plus que 5 après je pense que
c'est un joueur qui a le volume physique
d'une part et puis le talent pour
s'adapter mais je le vois pas
nécessairement dans un pureau le 5 small
ball ce serait privé d'une partie du
talent
ok merci pour ta question Paul je
reviens vers toi Josselin est-ce que tu
as préparé une autre question
j'avais une autre petite question c'est
un peu plus perso parce que moi je suis
fan de mini Sota et du coup on a le 19
et moi il y avait donc il y avait trois
noms que j'aimais beaucoup
enfin dans plein de noms mais il y en a
trois que j'aime beaucoup il y avait
Marc Williams mais j'ai l'impression que
ça va être un peu short j'avoue qu'il y
a pas mal d'équipes avant qui pourraient
ne pas le laisser passer mais c'est mon
préféré j'avoue j'avais Walker Kessler
que j'aime beaucoup pourquoi pas le
développer dans un espèce de Lopez un
Milo qui un truc comme ça je vais vous
en parliez dans le Sketchup et j'aimais
bien black Wesley aussi
du coup je voulais savoir si je voulais
savoir si vous aviez un avis sur le pic
19 des Wolf et
un gars qui est prêt à jouer ce que tu
recherches un projet est-ce que tu
recherches plutôt un joueur intérieur là
tu m'as cité deux intérieurs mais black
Wesley c'est un jour à rien
pour moi il y a plein de pistes à
explorer
je pense que on peut on peut tout à fait
prendre un joueur qui est capable de
jouer maintenant comme on peut prendre
quelqu'un qui a moyen à long terme est
capable de bousculer la hiérarchie par
exemple je pense à la hiérarchie quand
je dis Blake Wesley c'est la hiérarchie
en rotation sur les postes 1 2 qui est
occupés par j'ai le Noël et Jordan
mclefield est-ce que un mec comme Blake
Wesley un peu plus grand que pour moi
des qualités différentes en tout cas de
pas de Beverley et dont je le Russell
pour moi ça peut ne pas être intéressant
après il y a aussi le projet de faire
jouer car Antony Town 104 qui a été
beaucoup mentionné ces derniers temps du
moins sur certaines séquences
donc pour moi il y a pas mal de
possibilités en fonction ce qu'on veut
faire et Walker alors j'aime beaucoup
Marco Williams
Manu répond et on accueille Alan comment
ça va ça va et toi tu as bien mangé
ça va il fallait il fallait que j'allais
tomber merci beaucoup non moi je reste
pas dans ces conditions il a vu pauvre
colonne de CD derrière lui il n'y a pas
une armoire il y a rien
les joies de l'étudiant
la question de Jocelyn manu a Minnesota
qu'elle parmi les trois cités marque
Williams Walker Kessler Blake Wesley
quel profil t'intéresse
effectivement le combiné
[Musique]
Town Mark Williams et sur le papier
super intéressant parce que je trouve
que les deux se combinent vraiment bien
mais comme 48 ans peuvent peser à 3
points et un Marc Williams stream Runner
comme ça protecteur de cercle ça peut
être vraiment cool après Blake ou Isley
j'ai un peu plus de mal à le voir en
tant que porteur de balle Bollène Blur 1
2 comme ça qui passe sur ce qu'on a vu
cette dernière Notre-Dame j'ai un peu
plus de mal à l'avoir comme ça même si
j'aime bien les outils défensifs c'est
plus offensivement que j'ai du mal à
avoir un rôle tout de suite en fait même
si ce sera en sortie de banc
et Kessler pourquoi pas aussi c'est ça
mais je c'est compliqué je trouve de le
voir maintenant
associée à atteindre par exemple parce
que les lui aussi peut s'écarter lui un
peu plus protecteur de cercle peut-être
qu'un timbre mais on sortit pourquoi pas
plus en tout cas je les vois pas ce
souci tous les deux sur le terrain en
tout cas donc là si tu si les trois sont
dispo en 19
c'est Marc Williams Kessler et Wesley
dans cet ordre
est-ce que tu mets un pouce bleu
pourquoi drafter à l'intérieur
ça c'est le raisonnement d'Alan durant
toute sa vie c'est pourquoi le Rafale à
l'intérieur
moi j'aime bien l'idée d'avoir un mec
comme si tes marques Williams comme ma
fille préférée un mec qui peut venir
soit en backup de 40 minutes ça aussi si
on regarde en tant que 5 majoritairement
cette saison soit un mec qui pourra
tourner derrière le nouveau 5 si on
place beaucoup 40 minutes en quatre
comme c'est évoqué récemment du coup
j'aime beaucoup le profil de Mark
williamster à l'intérieur mais tu te
draft qui à la place
des ailiers toujours qui
Harrison est là je me jette dessus si
j'allais et William c'est là je le
prends je pense si au chaque bagier là
je le prends si
[Musique]
c'est déjà trois noms après Mark William
c'est vrai que le profil de raymerunner
se draft mais c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être un peu haut pour pour un
simple prime Runner je trouve mais ça
peut clairement faire sens il y a pas du
tout ce qu'on avait juste c'est vrai que
je préfère aux côtés
ou les joueurs qui ont qui peuvent un
peu poser
un niveau un niveau moyen plus je trouve
que c'est quand même intéressant
super pièces je pense que je complète ça
romain qu'est-ce que tu en penses de
marque Williams
si tu as vu manquero tu as eu marqué
Williams je me remets juste sur ce que
j'avais noté sur l'animal ces derniers
jours
j'aime bien la mobilité après ce qui me
fait peur c'est que le skill 7 il est
encore un peu rudimentaire je pense que
entre lui et faire de toute façon à deux
vrais beaux bébés défensifs dans des
registres un petit peu différents lui
est peut-être un peu plus un peu plus
mobile un peu plus verticale il peut
switcher là où Kessler on n'est pas
forcément capable
après moi je me pose aussi la question
de la complémentarité que tu peux avoir
éteindre parce que c'est toujours bien
dans la construction d'une équipe quand
on peut d'avoir des joueurs qui peuvent
jouer ensemble c'est bien mais d'avoir
aussi deux options différentes c'est à
dire que clairement pour moi si ça doit
partir sur un poste 5 en considérant
towns prendra des minutes sur poste 5 il
vaut mieux avoir un profil qui soit
l'opposé du chien inévitablement pour
avoir différentes options sur le liner
dans ce cas là les deux sont cohérents
me plaît bien je dois creuser encore un
peu mais qu'est-ce-que me plaît bien par
la dureté que William sa pas forcément
tout le temps par contre je pense que le
plafond est peut-être
un peu plus un poil plus élevé peut-être
chez Williams je pense pas que Chrysler
il est un le plancher de kestler il est
solide déjà ce qui est de bonne poutres
en dessous mais je pense pas que le le
plafond caisse là est très haut par
contre Kessler c'est pour moi s'il est
prêt à jouer à les mettre des des des
coups de casseroles aujourd'hui il y a
pas de souci il peut on peut lancer dans
le grand bain mais par contre la
progression sera pas sera pas d'un tu
sais ce que tu as en le signant c'est
l'intérêt mais c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle Kessler et peut-être
projeté un peu plus bas par certains que
que Williams
c'est ce que tu disais il est moins de
diversité défensive aussi en tant que en
tant que pivot c'est à dire que Williams
peut-être qui pourra switcher à terme
qui est cela ça va être compliqué
et puis oui William il a il a un truc
intéressant c'est que c'est vraiment
Nord Sud Est-Ouest il peut bouger
latéralement il peut courir voilà
Kessler il nous arrive tout droit des
années 90 mais c'est pas si malgré tout
y compris dans le rendement statistique
qui peut avoir il a fait deux
j'ai repris un peu les stats hier ou ce
midi
avec des contre l'histoire ça arrive pas
souvent quand même et c'est ça reste une
machine donc après faut le transposer au
niveau NBA bien sûr la verticalité par
la même en face
malgré tout c'est du brutal quoi
Kendrick Perkins au lycée
au deuxième tour c'est là peut-être que
tu peux tenter à l'intérieur aussi
oui pourquoi pas il y aura un paramètre
aussi sur les vols je pense et qui a eu
une restruque il y a une restructuration
continue sur toute la saison et
l'assistant j'aime que je connais qui
était enquêté en charge notamment du
scouting et l'évaluation il est sorti
lors de la dernière vague de
reconstruction il y a quelques semaines
et ça c'est des choses dans un dans un
process de draft ça peut toujours
toujours avoir un impact notamment sur
les perspectives et sur sur la
construction
tu as ta réponse je sais alors tu en as
pas une claire mais voilà
parfait
on va on va accueillir un représentant
des Spurs donc Jocelyn je te remercie
pour être passé pour être passé pour
vous les gars des questions et qu'est-ce
que vous faites pour la draft chez 50
obligatoirement mais on va suivre ça
tranquille OK et ben si vous si vous
n'avez rien à faire n'hésitez pas nous
on est chez bean et chez forsteam
effectivement
ça marche
merci bonne soirée les gars merci pour
l'invite à plus
constant est-ce que tu as une autre
question où est-ce que je prends une
question du chat ouais ben j'en ai une
qui peut être en lien là avec ce que
j'ai vu dans le chat ça concerne
monsieur tarize
il y a pas mal de bon je sais qu'elle a
le même beaucoup donc on partage ce
point commun
j'ai vu quand j'ai vu votre scooter
report il y avait pas mal de problèmes
associés au comportement de tarisme
moi je les vois ces comportements mais
je suis pas prêt à aller considérer
comme un énorme défaut comme quelque
chose qui peut pas corriger est-ce que
vous de votre côté vous pensez que que
ces problèmes de comportement peuvent
être gommés s'il tombe dans la bonne
franchise et dans le le bon contexte
comme par exemple
10 de manière très très objective ok ici
ce que vous pensez que dans une
franchise comme ok si qui est quand même
une franchise qui s'est bien développée
ses roues qui donne une bonne mentalité
il peut gommer ses problèmes de ces
sautes d'humeur
moi je pense que oui parce que c'est
c'est on en parlait un point privé
justement de ça nous notre limite c'est
qu'on sait pas ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des programmes donc on peut
pas trop évaluer la personnalité
psychologique des personnes là c'est en
l'occurrence
sur des temps morts où il dit qu'il
écoute pas forcément le coach et qui
fait n'importe quoi après les temps
morts
moi je trouve que ça en dit plus long
sur la relation qu'il a avec ses
entraîneurs
que sur lui-même sa psychologie ça se
trouve s'il est dans un autre programme
où il y a déjà changé deux fois donc
c'est un peu un peu déjà ça peut
interpeller
si il se retrouve dans le bon ouais si
on se retrouve dans le bon contexte
franchement ça pour moi il y a pas de
lit il y a pas de drapeau supprimer le
drapeau jaune mais encore une fois on
est limité par nos connaissances
malheureusement là on peut pas trop dire
si
il est entre guillemets il est con ou
aussi finalement il est juste pas
heureux où il était quoi ce qui est un
peu bizarre parce que c'est lui qui a
choisi d'aller à LSU mais je sais plus
sur quel podcast vous en parliez ou sur
quoi les choses c'est un programme très
particulier qui a été englué dans les
affaires avec la le FBI donc là le 97%
du roadster c'est barré ils ont perdu
tous leurs joueurs recrutés ils ont plus
de coach
donc on coulisse un peu le merdier donc
peut-être que si ça peut jouer sur sur
la faible du joueur peut-être mais là
encore une fois c'est c'est des
questions auxquelles on peut pas
répondre et par contre et puis aussi
j'ajoute avant de parler à Romain il y a
aussi un effet boule de neige en donner
il y a deux SCA haute conduire bon on
n'est pas très stable mentalement et là
tous les médias font des caisses c'est
énorme enfin c'est pas normal mais je
veux dire c'est les mots graves que oui
il y a des doutes sur machin du coup il
descend de 5 places etc il y a forcément
des des équipes qui vont l'aimer même
s'il est même s'il a les sautes d'humeur
il y a forcément des workouts qui va
réussir
toute façon il y a des personnes qui
font que ça aussi pour que le joueur qui
les intéresse monte ou descend ils sont
dans leur rôle
romain est-ce que c'est risqué de
drafter
ce que je vois sur le
sur la dureté la dureté du bonheur
je pense que il fait partie de ces
joueurs qu'on bagarre culturel et
un passé qui fait que
la bagarre donc c'est plutôt bien j'aime
me battre comme dirait l'autre
après je suis toujours
j'aime bien en fait que j'ai regardé les
joueurs un petit peu sur les
comportements garder les lieux de
naissance
et il vient d'un coup en fait en
Virginie où les joueurs que j'ai croisé
qui viennent de cette partie là de des
États-Unis
sont souvent souvent je sais pas si
c'est espèce de tradition locale dans le
développement mais sont souvent assez
compliqué à gérer
est-ce que tu as des exemples que tu
n'es pas les données parce que non j'ai
pas donné le nom parce que
je dis pas que ce sont des joueurs
parlant parce qu'ils font peur peut-être
ces gens ouais ouais puis c'est souvent
des c'est souvent des des joueurs qui
vont avoir des personnalités très
marquées une petite heure de haut niveau
personnalité très marquée et pour pas
dire très haut niveau détermination
après c'est toujours pareil il est au
niveau des terminations et de et le
joueur un peu cramé c'est toujours très
très tenu moi j'aime bien ce que je vois
je trouve il y a des limites il y a des
limites un peu un peu techniques c'est
encore un peu frustre pour pas dire très
très haut sous certains aspects mais la
main gauche
il y en a pas donc comme ça la question
se pose pas mais malgré tout je pense
que sur la dureté sur l'impact ça peut
peut-être se transposer par contre les
faiblesses techniques sont quand même
très présentes parce que pour répondre
avec qui non ça n'a rien à voir avec les
Californiens les Californiens sont très
durs à mettre en route et californien
ils ont parfois du mal à s'inquiéter sur
ce qui se passe ils sont toujours
US coachies coach mais c'est pas non non
Virginie on est sur le sur l'autre côté
de l'autre côté du spectre pour répondre
à la question de Joe danielos
moi je pense que ce qui me fait peur
avec lui c'est la le côté un peu frustré
techniquement
si dans la tête ça passe pas un cap ça
peut vite être explosif parce que la
situation d'échecs dès qu'elle va
arriver ça va être compliqué et puis on
sait quand NBA toute façon il y a il y a
des spécialistes de ces situations là où
quand on sait qu'un jeune joueur comme
ça est pas forcément très stable c'est
très très facile d'aller le chercher et
d'aller le secouer et on se retrouve
vite aussi être entre guillemets
victimes du des étiquettes donc il y a
l'écran de fumée très certainement moi
je serai prudent il a des choses
intéressantes mais
[Musique]
je serai prudent
je conclurai par une simple statistique
si on regarde les stats avancées en tant
que contre et interception pourcentage
et puis 10 ans personne ne fait mieux
une scie
et il y a que Robert kovington et Mathis
tables qui sont un peu dans sa dans sa
zone mais lui il jouait pas en zone
comme Tyber la Washington et il jouait à
l'issue dans un une grosse conférence
donc moi c'est un point physiquement
c'est un playmaker assez incroyable
physiquement il est assez incroyable il
y a des progrès pour passer de 57% à 80%
lancé francs en une année ça peut
prouver qui peut progresser 36% trois
points à progresser aussi après bien sûr
c'est un risque c'est un risque mais je
pense que le potentiel défensif plus
si on arrive un peu à le cadrer dans une
de choses offensivement il peut être
vraiment vraiment incroyable son
physique aussi et très très
impressionnant donc
le nouveau méta
peut-être mais donc ça veut dire que il
mérite une sélection top 10 alors parce
que renarter se mérite une sélection ou
méta comme
dans un top 18
moi je prendrai le risque parce que un
moment dans la draft je trouve une chute
quand même sur le potentiel donc il
mérite je pense
de toute façon
c'est quand même assez risqué mais
pour prendre des risques parfois est-ce
qu'il y a eu des bruits constants ok si
les dirigeants aimaient bien tarifs
avec la franchise là il en a parlé hier
là parce que tout le monde est en train
de faire la salle vedine interview donc
là tu as plein de rumeurs qui sont en
train d'être balancer attire la Rigot il
a effectué un workout avec le sonder
après il y a énormément de joueurs dans
ce range qu'on effectue un workout
évidemment mais lui a dit que ça c'était
plutôt bien passé il avait dîné avec
toute la franchise il avait rencontré
tout le monde les restants en contact
avec la franchise
donc c'est c'est je sais pas si ça va
déboucher sur une draft mais en tout cas
comme beaucoup de prospects il y a peu
de prospects bizarrement qui disent non
moi mon workout c'est très mal passé
avec la franchise j'étais mal reçu mais
en tout cas oui il fait partie des
joueurs qui peuvent potentiellement
intéresser le Thunder effectivement
est-ce qu'on sait ce qu'il a mangé
non non j'ai pas j'ai pas l'info les
insiders du Thunder l'ont pas ressorti
malheureusement ce qui aurait été
capital mais non j'ai pas l'info
romain je suis en rapport on est sur un
rapport de risque moyen moyen plus mais
pour une récompense qui peut être du
même du même
du même niveau on va dire donc c'est pas
c'est pas intéressant dans le contexte
et bien je vais prendre une question du
chat constant tu peux rester avec nous
on attend les prochains
avec plaisir est-ce que tu as d'autres
est-ce que tu as d'autres joueurs dans
le nom revient comme ça pour le pic 12
au Thunder est-ce que ce n'est plus sur
un trade il y avait des murs de trade
il y a une grosse rumeur c'est le trade
pour aller chercher shaydenshot ça de
toute façon c'est la grosse rumeur là
qu'il y a en flamme tout le monde sait
que le JM des pélicans était du côté
d'Istanbul il y a à peu près deux
semaines pour aller voir jouer missich
donc c'est pas innocent ça veut dire que
il y a certainement des tôles que qui
ont été lancés entre les Belges et le
Thunder pour un swap missile plus douce
plus des Twix contre le pick 8 après
est-ce que ça va déboucher sur une grave
de charpe je sais pas ça reste toujours
les rumeurs de draft effectivement la
grosse rumeur c'est chez un sharp
ensuite il y a des petits il y a des
petits il y a la rumeur Jérémy Swan qui
a pas mal enflé il y a de ça deux trois
semaines parce que le joueur était très
vocal sur ce qu'il a fait avec le
Thunder il y a au chèque Belgique à
faire workout où ça s'est très bien
passé Johnny Davis a été en contact
quasiment tout le temps avec la
franchise depuis depuis le combat c'est
pareil pour être film donc il y a pas
mal de prospects finalement il y en a
juste
[Musique]
non mais alors déjà il est pas candidat
Mathieu il est plus candidat en tout cas
pour moi
il me semble qu'il y a transfert je vais
vérifier ça mais mais sinon mais sinon
Alan est-ce que tu peux répondre à
Mathieu
franchement c'est un super joueur
offensif franchement il est il a des
attributs techniques et même physique
dans les petits dans les dans les petits
espaces qui sont super anormaux plus son
poids parce que tu dois faire combien
125 kg 120 125 kg pour 2 mètres
quasiment donc sur ça c'est super
intéressant pour moi la limite c'est le
tir extérieur parce qu'en fait c'est pas
un protecteur de cercle donc en NBA
c'était labellisé grand et que tu
protèges pas le cercle il faut vraiment
que tu aies un tir extérieur pour qu'on
puisse te mettre avec un protecteur de
cercle sauf que pour l'instant c'est
vraiment un genre de post bas de post-up
finition cercle rebond offensif
puissance donc
je mets pas une croix sur lui à jamais
mais pour l'instant vu qu'il tire pas je
peux et qu'il est et qu'il a pas perdu
du poids je peux pas le je peux pas le
drafter mais
c'est un vrai joueur de basket
alors moi j'ai juste regardé les trois
premières possessions défensives de
du NBA combine
ils prennent trois paniers à cause de
lui son équipe il y a pas il y a pas de
il y a pas de mystère etc il se fait
bouffer sur deux switchs et il y en a un
autre où il est plus petit que son
adversaire
[Musique]
comme ça donc ça sera peut-être un bon
joueur européen mais enfin moi j'y crois
pas une seule seconde en NBA et je suis
peut-être trop catégorique et j'espère
qu'il me fera mentir pas de problème
Manu tu as quelque chose à ajouter sur
ce qu'elle dit à là
non mais je suis comme toi je le vois
plus en Europe à terme
n'oubliez pas du tout
c'est ce qui paraît logique nous allons
accueillir un nouvel invité ce qui a
c'est notre ami binge
bonsoir à tous salut
les gars désolé pour le retard j'osais
pas cliquer sur le lien de peur de
m'incrustrer m'incruster dans le stream
de façon impromptue il y a pas de
problème tu es là et tu es il y a une
salle d'attente la vie est bien faite
et donc tu es là tu as une question
qui va être le
porte-voix de la communauté des Spurs à
travers cette question
des responsabilités
alors
il y a eu beaucoup de et on a bon étant
donné que les sports ont un pic du top
10 de la draft évidemment il y a
beaucoup de de noms qui sont sortis dans
les dans les rumeurs ça a beaucoup parlé
de ça beaucoup parlé de Jason duren on a
vu du Jérémy Soran on a vu tout plein de
joueurs
la question c'est si les Spurs avec
leurs pics 9 veulent chercher le un
joueur qui va les faire
peut-être le peut-être le potentiel
prochain visage de la franchise en tout
cas vraiment le meilleur joueur
disponible
qui est-ce qui est-ce qui devrait aller
chercher le plus haut potentiel
un joueur qui a un peu enquête un
potentiel de star qui pourrait être le
franchise plusieurs de l'équipe dans
quelques années donc plus un potentiel
plus haut que des jeunes qui à l'heure
actuelle j'imagine
on considère être le franchise player
j'espère absolument absolument
très bien avez-vous des idées
le plus s'en rapprocher
maintenant
c'est vraiment quelque chose de auquel
on peut croire aujourd'hui ça donne
charpente 9 je sais que ça coûte baisse
beaucoup mais est-ce que descendre
jusque là
j'en ai aucune idée ça vite mais sachant
que le Picwic est à vendre entre
guillemets qui a oki Road avec ses 28
graphiques sur les
années on a encore récupéré un il y a 3
jours la contrôle pic 30 là ça me
précise toujours en train de faire ses
emplettes et de piquer des piques à tous
les JM
ce serait étonnant qui passe suite mais
je dis juste ça les sports ont aussi le
droit de monter d'une place s'ils le
veulent absolument
le souci c'est que
traditionnellement trouver un mec qui
soit pied en lumière d'une franchise
dans ces eaux là c'est difficile
il est enfin j'en ai discuté il y a
quelques années avec un scoot elle
disait avec lui il préférait soit se
retrouver dans la situation de choisir
entre 20 et 30 soit entre 20 et 5 mais
entre les deux c'est compliqué parce que
tu jettes la pièce en fait et je pense
que les sports ne sont jamais aussi bons
quand hydrate on va dire peut-être pas
bam et au-delà de la 14 15e place parce
que c'est peut-être là on peut faire le
plus de coups
là historiquement des des pixels 8 9
devenus des joueurs cadres dans des
équipes
le spécialiste de ces choses-là c'est
c'est un peu Antoine qui aurait pu nous
trouver encore des stats totalement
improbables à dessus mais tu pas sûr que
faut pas se rater quoi
ok alors les noms qui sont beaucoup
ressortis en tout cas de qu'on a discuté
chez nous qu'on a vu des joueurs qui
nous intéressait en tout cas de par leur
profil on a des Jérémy Soran on est très
fan mais c'est pas en cas de dans cette
question là je pense pas que ça soit un
joueur qui rentre dans ses critères
un joueur nous nous l'idée enfin ce
qu'on se disait c'est peut-être entre
Johnny Davis ou Bénédicte Mathurin des
joueurs qui ont peut-être un potentiel
de créateurs secondaires
dans une équipe qui sont déjà des
scorers
qui ont déjà qui sont déjà avancés en
termes de scoring qu'est-ce que on peut
attendre de ces joueurs lequel serait si
les deux sont disponibles dans le dans
la situation d'expérience lesquelles
seraient le plus value Apple
qu'est-ce qui peut les différencier
et avant je fais un correctif à mea
culpa
Cannes of town est bien candidat alors
c'est tout j'ai fini
qu'est-ce qui peut les différencier je
dirais la défense entre des vis et
maturant donc
selon moi plus développé défensivement
après en terme de jouer offensif je
trouve qu'ils se ressemblent un peu une
qui est plus porté sur le trois points
l'autre qui est plus porté sur le mi
distance
mais la différence moi se fait sur
vraiment sur le jeu défensif mais je
vois moi je les vois pas
potentiel star en fait là comme ça très
bon porteur d'eau les deux je trouve
très bon très bon dans un rôle d'option
secondaire ou tertiaire sur liquide
comme les Spurs je voulais les deux sont
clairement sont clairement compatibles
avec la maison après voilà de la
dernière star je pense pas par contre
dans les deux cas tu sais ce que tu as
tu es curieusement il revient toujours
hein c'est des sophro morts
donc tu sais un peu plus où tu vas
ok
vas-y pardon
était plus développé défensivement que
Johnny Davis
c'est vrai que c'est pas le son plus
bien relevé justement c'est plutôt le
l'inverse qui ressort que bennique
Mathurin est un peu flemmardant surtout
ovball qu'est-ce que
du coup qu'est-ce qui te fait dire que
qui serait plus développé
ça c'est que moi c'est ce que j'ai vu en
tout cas après j'ai vu le plus l'un que
l'autre mais je l'ai vu super
intéressant notamment sur les outils
défensifs et une très bonne envergure je
trouve qu'il aille qui bouge bien
latéralement je trouve que il est pas
encore capable de
s'occuper de position que ça moi je le
vois plus sur du 2-3 mais je j'aime bien
ce que j'ai vu plus que plus que que des
vis où j'ai vraiment des vies j'ai adoré
offensivement par contre plus qu'un
Maturin en terme de
développement de jeu de capacité à
attirer à créer l'espace mais
défensivement je puisse accrocher sur
surmaturin peut-être à cause de l'équipe
parce que Arizona c'est quand même très
très bien huilé très bien coacher c'est
peut-être à cause de ça et que du coup
je suis un peu c'est un peu biaisé mais
moi j'ai plus apprécié le voir en
défense que
les outils défensifs que ce que
qu'est-ce que ton dis sur les deux
moi d'instin je dirais que
Mathurin est peut-être plus un joueur à
faire défendre fort sur le sur le le
point d'attaque et Johnny Davis un gars
qui va naviguer les écrans etc
je pense que je pense que physiquement
maturant est vraiment une bière Eddie
Johnny Davy s'il peut prendre un bon
défenseur aussi mais des deux côtés du
terrain il prend un côté boule de
flipper quand ça dure si
tendance à se faire taper un petit peu
et c'est pas c'est pas simple quoi je
trouve que sur cet aspect vraiment
des vis naturellement mature en plus de
garantie pour moi et mature a plus de
garantie pour vraiment rentrer dans le
dans le côté un peu du NDI dont tu auras
besoin dont tu auras besoin des Spurs à
l'inverse des vis il est quasiment
ouvert bon moyen ce qui pour son poste
est quand même super intéressant
également donc
il y a des outils dans les deux cas
pas évident ensuite je rater plus
facilement avec des vis
il y a pas de jeu mis de range pour
mettre sur un il y a du bon et du moins
bon donc débrouillez vous récupérez deux
pics pour par rapport au renfort choisir
en 89 ou un CDI ou c'était la pièce pour
savoir lesquels vous prenez mais dans
les détails
dans les deux cas il y a pas de il y a
pas d'erreur de casting pour moi ça
reste deux mecs qui sont
qui sont intelligents qui peuvent faire
des choses Johnny Davis il a un côté
deuxième option dans le fait de pouvoir
porter le ballon que que Mathieu un
appât en attaque par exemple naturel
moins aller sur pick and roll donc on
est vraiment sur deux mecs qui seraient
qui seraient complémentaires si je vois
ensemble d'ailleurs
tu veux prendre un risque Griffin
je pense que c'est possible je pense que
honnêtement je pense que c'est possible
ok
Griffin écharpe sont ceux que tu peux
vraiment ceux si le meilleur scénario
peut être une star mais le pire scénario
le scénario médian peut être bien plus
bas que des vis et mature et vice et
mature ou un plancher bien supérieur je
pense même si le tir de Griffin pour sa
taille et fait que il sera toujours
utile en fait dans une rotation
et la Chine en fait
si tu veux vraiment aller sur le
potentiel potentiel
a plus de chances de changer ta
franchise que Johnny Davis ou ben matura
honnêtement si ça fonctionne
si ça marche mais il y a aussi une
chance que
il y a aussi une chance que ça que ça
que ça fonctionne mal c'est je pense que
Davis est mature vraiment ça sera de
Solid joueur NBA qui font plusieurs
contrats et qui s'incorporeront très
bien dans le projet des sters d'ailleurs
à côté de Primo vacel qu'elle donne
Johnson Murray je pense que vraiment ça
s'incorpore très bien mais je pense que
Weasley ou
charpent Griffin comme l'a dit ou il
sonne peuvent être ceux qui peuvent
potentiellement avoir plus de potentiel
mais ça prendra un risque il y a une
chose que ça ne marche pas dans ma note
idéal j'ai mis heissonne voilà ce sera
incroyable
Johnson avec
wasselière et il va développer un petit
peu de technique sur le Drive pour pour
exploiter ses qualités qui
je vais essayer de ne pas être trop long
mais du coup pour pour résumer le l'idée
c'est que un ben Maturin ou un Johnny
Davis ont moins risqué qu'un black
westly ou un char ou DJ Griffin mais du
coup il y a moins aussi un potentiel de
de stars ou de enfin le plafond est
moins haut sur ces deux joueurs
en tout cas le plafond perçu après par
exemple moi je fais partie des gens qui
pensent que Bénédicte Mathurin il lui
manque pas énormément de choses dans
dans son bagage technique pour accéder à
être je sais pas une troisième option
d'une vraiment très très bonne équipe
s'il devient élite shooter en mouvement
qu'il est déjà il est déjà très bon et
qui peut juste poser deux dribbles au
sol
jouer un pick and roll de fin de
possession avec un corner vide ce genre
la même chose
il peut clairement peser dans une très
très bonne équipe parce que Manu est
romain l'ont dit c'est aussi un bon
défenseur donc il aura du temps de jeu
pour se développer et pour avoir des
répétitions sur ces phases de jeu là
sublime
du coup alors oui autre question vous
m'arrêtez quand ça commence à devenir
chiant le
une des différences que dont on va
parler notamment Hugues de chez vous qui
m'avait parlé de ça c'est la différence
de Haendel entre Johnny Davis et
Benedict Mathurin ou Johnny Davis plus
important de balle sachant que c'est un
profil qu'on a déjà pas mal au Spurs
l'idée d'un joueur qui aussi développé
un Haendel devient All Star
est-ce que c'est un peu la même
situation pour pour Ben Mathurin donc
c'est finalement un des gros axes de
progression ou est-ce qu'il est dans une
quête d'autre catégorie
il y a un truc romain disait dans notre
conversation privée l'autre fois au
moins tu disais après attention aussi du
contact ça fait partie du handle mais
voilà c'est qu'il y a pas de garder le
contact avec le dribble en vie quoi
et puis
je trouve je trouve mature un peu plus
un peu plus dense un peu plus vigne
droite que le nez des vis sur certains
aspects c'est à dire que Mathurin on est
de plus en puissance et c'est aussi ce
qui fait qu'il est pas
moins allé sur piquenrol puis bon ça
main gauche c'est un petit peu c'est un
petit peu une zone de non-droit elle
n'existe pas trop donc
les choses mises bout à bout fait que
moi je suis sceptique comme porteur de
balle même secondaire pour Mathurin le
voit plus vraiment dans un rôle
dans un rôle défensif bout de chaîne
capable d'apporter des petites choses
par ci par là mais
pas créer quoi
pas créer défenses défenseur finisseur
qui a peu de faire différentes choses
mais
plutôt de la vie de Hugues donc c'est
pour ça Hugues un peu plus bas que nous
d'ailleurs dans son board il disait pour
moi c'est un très bon flux Andy
potentiel mais pas plus
ouais c'est ça il a une vraie énergie il
y a des choses intéressantes mais
je sais pas il y a quelque chose que
[Musique]
je sais pas il y a un truc qui me il
manque un petit quelque chose ne manque
un petit quelque chose après il teste
starter incontournable à Arizona bon
voilà il y a des garanties pour lui
aussi moi j'aime beaucoup ce que je vois
quand je le vois mais je le vois
vraiment dans le rôle dans le rôle sport
du joueur qui défend qui prend les tirs
et puis qui apportent ce qu'il faut à
l'équipe un petit peu derrière
tu prends pas ombrage mais je prends une
petite question du chat pour pas qu'on
parle que des Spurs même si du coup on
parle des prospects aussi mais les
Raptors pour le coup on n'a pas parlé
ils ont que le 33 et notre ami Mike
nous demande
est-ce que j'en monte terreau ah oui
j'ai mis j'en Montereau à torse dans mon
mode de graphe ce qui est pas du tout un
style de joueur Raptor pour le coup
défense first et polyvalence pour te
répondre Mike nous je Montereau c'est ni
défenseur ni polyvalence ni régularité
c'est vrai
mais je l'adore
quel autour de cette place là le 33
début de seconde tour à l'âne est-ce que
tu as des idées de profil qui pourrait
convenir à deux adjectifs du coup
d'abord de la défense et de la
polyvalence
le patron épais mais qui peut s'épaissir
et qui a des des attributs techniques
qui sont pas qui vont pas trop ou des
attributs de son jeu qui vont pas être
encore qu'il a et je pense que comme
cabas et pourquoi pas sur le fait que
c'est un des meilleurs défenseurs en
switch je pense du championnat c'est
l'an dernier alors qui il fait de 10
donc je pense que ça peut être un profil
comme ça
peut vraiment dalen terrible mais il
sera plus là à l'intérieur il y a une
trouble trop belle coach je pense il
sera pris le genre d'Arizona de
coéquipier de Mathurin rien ne Rollins
de Toledo ouais je pense que ou
trevorkills peut-être c'est pas
très grand pour décrire son profil et
pas 92 il fait 91 mais il fait 2,8
d'envergure
différentiel taille en vergure derrière
c'est ça donc c'est sur les c'est un
vrai combo qui pourrait développer je
pense
de qualité offensive aussi à l'âne très
fort sur le midraine le piratoires est
pas encore développé et 31% sur quatre
tentatives en deux ans à tous les deux
mais
79% lancé francs donc et on progrès plus
de 80% cette année un bon passeur
vraiment un bon passeur un bon rebondeur
pour sa taille aussi les longs bras ça
doit aider mais je pense que
ça peut vraiment faire sens rien de
rouler ça m'étonnerait pas du tout qui
tombe dans une équipe comme Toronto
est-ce que Manu t'as d'autres idées ou
est-ce qu'on passait une conférence de
la MAC il faut le rappeler
pour sa taille dans la MAC
un peu de respect sur la MAC quand même
c'est du respect
c'est vrai
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
Kendall brand
o alors Wilson il retourne à la fac
[Musique]
peut-être Marjo de Beauchamp oui
peut-être aussi
polyvalento
mais peut-être qu'au bout d'un moment
avoir des alliés interchangeables
c'est pour ça que j'avais mis un gars
il est trop petit
ou constant est-ce que vous avez une
question je vais descendre le fil du
chat pour voir si il y en a d'autres
après on accueillera notre ami des cases
alors moi je vous en prends mon dernier
juste avant de partir alors ce psychos
constant tu en avais une aussi non moi
de toute façon il faut que j'y aille
donc tu peux poser ta question
t'inquiète
sublime alors moi j'avais une question
concernant Jason duren qui a été qui a
beaucoup été discuté au Spurs en tout
cas dans la communauté et je me tourne
un petit peu vers Alan vu que je partage
en tout cas son avis qui défend a priori
corps et âme qui aide avec les
difficultés de drafté au des intérieurs
à la draft
est-ce que du coup c'est pour ça que
j'ai un peu de la peine à m'emballer
avec lui et à vraiment être enfin être
emballé par l'idée que l'espérance de
draft est-ce que il laissait un cas
spécial pour lui est-ce qu'il a vraiment
un potentiel qui mériterait qu'il soit
pique aussi haut qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous en dites
c'est un truc que j'aime le mieux depuis
que
c'est un peu comme Monica au Congo il y
a deux ans pour moi ils sont ils ont ils
sont trop fort quand même dans dans le
potentiel de protection de cercle menace
de l'Aube et ils ont été des aspects de
leur jeu qui sont qui s'apprennent pas
quand même pour des grands et qu'on
trouve pas partout on en parlait
d'ailleurs avec Romain je crois que
c'était en janvier on pourrait peut-être
des flashs à la poste d'urine qui se
sont un petit peu qui sont très brutes
mais qui se sont quand même vus sur le
cours de la saison manuel m'ira plus
souvent que duren c'est un joueur qui
peut shooter c'est pas parce qu'il l'a
pas montré il y a Memphis que il peut
pas le faire on l'a vu un monde vert de
faire un petit peu donc pour son âge
c'est tu crois le deuxième jour le plus
jeune de la draft pour ces attributs
physiques qui franchement ça prenne pas
et pour ça je pense quand même que dans
la deuxième partie de la loterie il
mérite une sélection quand même mais il
changera pas de cours mais il mérite
ok très très intéressant
qui te fait trois contrats que tu vas
jamais payé trop cher parce qu'il va pas
être super star mais qui va être très
solide comme intérieur Andy romain on
t'a jamais entendu sur une durée
du travail un petit peu pendant l'année
à ce moment-là non légèrement non non
vrai athlète
malgré la malgré l'âge c'est ce que
j'avais noté c'est que c'était quand
même physiquement une bière et dit et
surtout il y a un avantage qu'il a beau
être jeune il a pas peur quand ça quand
ça m'assode un petit peu ce qui est
plutôt plutôt bien
ça peut courir alors il y a des
évidences sur lesquels ils doivent
vraiment avancer tout ce qui va être lié
au fond d'un manteau du jour intérieur
mais comme on l'a dit il a reclassifié
donc il aurait dû être normalement
fraîchement que l'an prochain donc c'est
très jeune et pour un joueur intérieur
son prime va être dans 10 ans donc
on va dire qu'il a le temps de le temps
d'arriver à maturité quand même d'ici là
pas être trop pressé il y a plein de
choses plein de choses intéressantes
dont le fait qu'il soit capable de
passer
le plancher là grâce au niveau défensif
donc le risque le risque il est il est
moyen voire peu élevé parce qu'on sait
déjà ce qu'on a défensivement
physiquement techniquement mais la
récompense elle peut elle peut être
moyenne voire plus en fonction de
comment il se développe après je pense
que c'est typiquement le genre de joueur
même si c'est très très suspect au
lancer c'est typiquement le genre de
joueur mon avis qu'il faut pas pas
mettre dans un chantier un bordel en
construction trop trop vite parce que
parce que il faut du temps trois mois
fait 2,1 contre par match ça reste ça
reste plutôt plutôt soyez alors question
non j'ai pas payé non ça n'a rien à voir
avec la facture électricité c'est juste
que je suis l'éclairage naturel en ce
moment j'ai pas encore allumé
on va en parler de ça sur la deuxième
heure de Slive
vous remède miracle dans le chat merci
merci constant merci ben je vous laisse
retourner vaquer à vos occupations
peut-être pour constant une petite
reprise
d'Eddy Mitchell à la gratte
merci beaucoup d'être passé les gars on
vous souhaite
toujours un plaisir merci beaucoup pour
pour l'invitation
merci pour votre travail sans régal
merci pour tes compliments nous
rougissons
merci merci constant je te je te
désactive aussi je te laisse y aller
nous allons cueillir notre ami des caves
ciao constant
messieurs est-ce que vous avez vu alors
ah oui juste pour le chat avant qu'on
accueille notre notre ami de caves fr
les questions sur les Européens les
Français etc on a fait une vidéo il y a
deux jours en live Gabriel et Procida je
vois une question de the fa dièse
Gabriel
on en pense beaucoup de bien sur le
potentiel etc tu peux aller sur la fin
de notre life sur les Français je dirais
les trois derniers les 40 dernières
minutes on a Nico qui parle qui parle
très bien de ça avec avec Alan avec avec
Luca aussi donc voilà on a
fortitudo Bologne
le deuxième club de Bologne quoi
et pareil pour la question sur Nicolas
Jovic on en a passé on a passé un peu de
temps là dessus donc
nous pose la question incroyable il doit
être indirect de Manchester
assez assis
je t'avais demandé mais je sais pas si
tu l'as fait est-ce que tu as une haute
take
toujours
moi je vais dire où est-ce qu'il est
Brice McGowen
futur tweet player de légende légende
ah non j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
le potentiel en fait du garçon donc qui
joue à cette saison
High School aussi je j'ai vu un autre
contexte un autre rôle donc ce qui c'est
un peu ce qui me fait dire ça j'adore le
j'adore le physique long bras peu de 3
s'il veut et c'est moi mon X sur lui
c'est s'il veut défendre je pense qu'il
peut être un terme un très très bon
défenseur et j'adore le shoot même si la
shooté à 28% à 3 points comme je l'ai
dit avant je l'ai vu
faire des des cartons donc c'est pas ce
qui m'inquiète le plus donc c'est
vraiment ça
a même commencé à
faire à initier sur du piquet roll donc
c'est beaucoup de flash donc c'est plus
ça je pense qu'ils allaient dire
le style de frein de premier c'est le
joueur que moi j'ai vu qui a le plus
d'écart entre
films et stats
dégueulasse et après j'ai vu les matchs
et j'ai dit il est fort quand même ce
Brice il va arriver au cercle il met des
choses difficiles
alors après ça a l'air un peu mieux les
bracelets cette année quand même oui
pour la défense de la fluidité d'attaque
mais il avait vraiment le la plaie de
jouer avec Alonzo verge mais moi je
trouve que tu es dur là-dessus par
exemple parce que
il a fait des il a fait des cartes avec
ça pas de gauche
incroyable incroyable tenue de la Ligue
taïwanaise
on est dans une espèce de conversation
j'ai l'impression entendre des puristes
parler de jazz de jazz taïwanais ou des
trucs comme ça des joueurs totalement
improbables donc personne n'est pas
de l'extrême en fait aller chercher des
joueurs c'est un gars qui joue de l'alto
je l'ai entendu dans un duo avec un mec
un jour à la contrebasse voir mon truc
la question de Paul qui décidément a des
bonnes questions même si alors là c'est
vraiment Madame Irma parce qu'on n'en
sait rien
mais c'est rigolo
la liste des la liste des greenwing tu
veux dire qui sera le plus fort des noms
draftés ah oui mais là là la question
que j'ai mise
en exergue quel est le joueur or green
Room qui sera le premier appelé par Adam
Simon
[Musique]
il nous faut la liste de la Green Room
je l'ai pas sur moi voilà ce qui est pas
drôle c'est que les Green ils sont 25
tous les ans
la Green Room c'est de plus en plus tu
vois les les gars qui prennent pas de
risque quoi on ratissent large et puis
et puis après
j'ai la liste allez donc quelle est la
différence avec notre
top donc
Hero Beauchamp Branham Daniels Davis
Jing duren
isson Griffin Hardy en grain Ivy
Mathurin Murray charm Smith soshan
Washington Weasley et les deux Williams
John et Marx moi j'ai un nom
Jake
incroyable j'ai un nom et n'empêche que
j'ai lu la moque de diatrique pour
rigoler et
il a des intérêts
dès la fin des des jeans
donc
ouais juste avant la vingtaine quoi 17
18 19 visiblement donc je sais plus je
sais plus qui est à ce niveau là mais
après ça peut coller justement
Minnesota parlait tout à l'heure mais
même chez les boules pour les
requêtements
je sais pas après il y a egy leiddle qui
est souvent moqué
s'il a une promesse peut-être Houston
qui a pas fait le combat
et après je rêve de voyouston mais après
c'est
comme on aimerait tous voir Jovic à
Denver
je range mon frein
j'ai le palette de jeux de mots pour
Lidl là qui qui était prête
est-ce que tu vas
garderai
une personne de plus cressington revient
au plateau s'il y a plus de respiration
covid donc ça peut être sur le niveau va
remonter d'un cran quand même attention
à la surenchère
ça peut bah oui parce que Lidl c'est
il est pas dans la Green Room
il est pas dans la liste que j'ai vu
peut-être qu'elle a été actualisée
[Musique]
allez
on a fini sur cette sur cette question
amusante et nous accueillons Mathias
sont
@ le Yogo sur Twitter Mathias salut à
tous tu vas bien
je t'ai demandé de venir avec une hot
take comme ça on peut rebondir dessus
toi qui a qui a un big board qui est
visible d'ailleurs qui est épinglé
alors plutôt une hottage sur le les
prospects du premier tour je sais que tu
aimes tu as des chouchous qui sont plus
loin dans la draft mais on va essayer de
rester accessible quand même à ceux qui
vont se coucher avant 4 heures du matin
mais j'ai vu que vous en avez parlé un
petit peu tout à l'heure ouais on a
parlé de Paris
c'était donc Harrison sera un All Star
s
de séance de noter sur son carnet oui
c'est Manu secret
romain est-ce que c'est un scénario qui
est possible ou est-ce que les il y a
des lacunes techniques qui sont trop
grandes pour aller un peu plus loin dans
le dans le tarif Sunday
des joueurs des joueurs frustre
techniquement qui ont eu des carrières
de mémoire
doit être Howard c'est pas plus grand
technicien qu'on connaît c'est quand
même plutôt un burger et voilà c'est
comme quelqu'un qui a une carrière donc
je pense pas qu'il avait non plus une
panoplie technique incroyable à ses
débuts en NBA
s'il y avait un très gros QI défensif
mais ça n'a pas empêché pour plein de
raisons d'y arriver également donc des
joueurs des joueurs qui ne sont qui
n'étaient pas forcément des espèces ni
des
profils nécessairement fin au départ
m'ont réussir des belles carrières le
tout encore une fois c'est de comprendre
son rôle et d'avoir le rôle qui
correspond à ce qu'on peut apporter
c'est pour moi la clé là ce que j'ai
tout à l'heure sur sur notre ami Charles
Michel c'est-à-dire que le contexte dans
lequel il tombe et et le rôle qu'on va
lui donner si ça colle avec ce que lui
peut faire contrairement c'est parfois
passé cette année à l'issue
et le rôle qu'on va lui donner si ça
colle avec ce que lui peut faire
contrairement à ce qui s'est parfois
passé cette année à l'issue
et le rôle qu'on va lui donner si ça
colle avec ce que lui peut faire
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé cette
année à l'issue
tu as compris mais
Mathias toi qu'est-ce qui te fait penser
que c'est possible tu as parce que je
t'ai demandé
pour moi tarif run c'est le meilleur
défenseur vous êtes QF ou au moins un
top 3 donc sur cette base là qui est
déjà solide je vois aussi un up
sur le côté offensif sur l'athlète qui a
déjà tous les outils en main pour pour
accéder au NBA donc s'il arrive à se
mettre un peu plus de plomb dans la
cervelle
plus un contexte qui lui sera vraiment
favorable je vois pas pourquoi il
pourrait pas gratter au moins gratter
une position de All Star quoi
ok je suis mesuré avec cette histoire de
pont dans la cervelle parce que c'est
souvent un peu réducteur
je pense pas que le mec soit forcément
forcément avoir utile ou quoi que ce
soit c'est pour ça bien sûr faire
attention
ouais mais encore une fois
je comprends ce que tu veux dire mais
juste faut qu'on soit quand même mesuré
sur les mots qu'on utilise Davy des
joueurs parce que un on les connaît pas
deux on est des abrutis à les juger
comme ça depuis nos fauteuils on connaît
rien de leur vie de leur parcours et on
sait pas comment ils sont géré au
quotidien et et c'est des choses je
pense pas que le mec soit soit tête
Bruay ou autre
ni complètement complètement allumé
c'est c'est c'est
peut-être un peu plus fin que ça
concernant
du foie encore une fois je
fais une petite digression je m'excuse
Alex on part en arborescence là mais on
est souvent parfois
quand on observe les sportifs de haut
niveau à se moquer des échecs de ceci de
cela des gamelles et compagnies mais
je pense que les mecs ils ont ils ont
des choses dans la tête comme tout le
monde et
autant juger de comportement à certains
moments et de l'impact sur les
comportements pour avoir sur la
performance en instant T c'est normal je
pense pas qu'il faille préjugé de ce que
sont les athlètes réellement
[Musique]
le temps de jeu donc
on accueille on accueille Thomas
notre représentant des caves
magnifique projet capillaire
[Rires]
Thomas Thomas
dans la communauté sur Youtube
donne-nous ta question vas-y quelle est
ta question
ma question c'est que je viens de vous
lire dans un article que d'après Brian
windorf donc bon j'avoue que ça vaut en
tant que source les cases auraient
promis Ousmane diang de le sélectionner
s'il était disponible en 14
la question que j'ai du coup si vous
suivez le compte que vous voyez passer
nos tweet vous savez que on a deux
chouchous c'est Diane et Jane Williams
et du coup ma question va concerner une
semaine bien c'est est-ce que vous avez
une comparaison d'un joueur avec un
profil aussi attrayant mais qui est
aussi loin sur la courbe de
développement pour vraiment contribuer
dans une équipe qui veut jouer les
playoffs et qui veut
alors ça a coupé sur la fin mais on a
compris c'était un son digne des
premières années
est-ce que vous m'entendez Thomas ta
connexion
esthétie mais on a compris
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée je t'ai
mis en Newt en attendant que la
connexion soit soit meilleure c'est vrai
que ça nous rappelait les grandes heures
d'envergure quand on avait des grandes
coupures de son et ça rappelait aussi
les belles heures de l'ORTF des années
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
est-ce qu'on a une comparaison et si
même si on n'a pas de comparaison
combien de temps faut attendre en gros
voilà les points abordés par Thomas pour
pour cette équipe des caves à l'année
pas raison
c'est assez complexe moi je le vois plus
comme ce qu'on pouvait voir de Zaïr
William son dernier par exemple
du côté de qui a été pris par Memphis ou
ce qu'on pouvait voir de ce qu'on
pouvait penser de cameredish au moment
de sa draft par
les parce qu'elle était assez parlée
qui offensivement dans les catégories
jeunes ont toujours dominé parce qu'ils
étaient plus grands et plus forts que
que les autres qui dans un contexte donc
la NCA pour certains la NBA pour pour
Jane on met un peu plus de soucis mais
c'est normal avec la montée de niveau
mais qui ont quand même des des
attributs secondaires hors tertiaires
qui leur qui peuvent leur permettre de
rester sur le terrain pour James ça peut
être le tir notamment sa taille tire
bien la bien fini l'année NBA avec son
shoot extérieur mais c'est sûr que
en réalité c'est les joueurs avec un
plafond sans doute un joueur sans doute
avec un plafond plus haut que challen
Williams que tu apprécies
demain et sans doute un meilleur joueur
sur le terrain que
Ousmane Jane donc je pense que
je conçois après c'est un avis personnel
mais je pense que
je pense que ouais on est plus sur un
genre à laser Williams ça la
ce qu'on pouvait pour cette Kevin Knox
peut-être au moment où il se fait drafté
qui peut un peu tout faire rien
d'excellent mais sur lequel on compte
quand même sur son tir extérieur et sur
son cuit pour rester sur le terrain si
on remonte un peu
alors c'est pas c'est pas le même profil
mais à quelqu'un qui était finalement
assez bas sur sa courbe de progression
par rapport à ce qu'il est devenu c'est
pas le genre
il arrive en NBA il est
frustre il fait deux ans à frein
nostalgique
et il développe après c'est une courbe
de développement qui est rare
il avait déjà pouvait être plus proche
de Paul Georges que de Kevin Knox ça
m'arrangerait ah oui mais bon
on a pas trop vu encore Zaïa Williams
c'est comme rédige ça reste encore
toujours un concept plus qu'un joueur
qui peut contribuer et apporter c'est ça
qui me dérange un peu avec dingue
en plus dans une bonne équipe il était
pas normalement un peu légitime bon quoi
romain combien de temps
là on parle d'un joueur qui était qui
était en nationalu de l'an dernier qui
s'est exporté Camille 4-5 mois digérer
le contexte australien qui une fois
qu'il a digéré la partie comme ça
ce qui fait que ça cote qui était
on va pas dire inquiétante mais qui
était remise en question en décembre
janvier aujourd'hui les questions se
posent plus on sait qu'il y a quelque
chose moi sur les quelques personnes
avec qui j'ai pu en parler ces derniers
mois sur les versours que j'ai eu
c'était en gros que la seule limite
qu'il avait c'était lui-même sur
énormément d'aspects parce que c'est un
vrai vrai talent pour plein de raisons
donc moi je dis si trois ans un joueur
pour l'évaluer et encore une fois on
parle de quelqu'un qui est jeune et qui
vient de changer de contexte qui vient
de partir à sans que ce soit une
métaphore à l'autre bout du monde pour
jouer au basket ça prouve qu'il est
capable de s'adapter donc déjà je pense
que quand on sait s'adapter comme ça
c'est qu'on a intelligent je m'inquiète
pas pour lui après derrière
inévitablement
faut pas s'attendre à quelqu'un de
d'impact tout de suite dès le début de
saison prochaine sauf que assez vite ça
peut apporter de la polyvalence ça peut
apporter les choses quand je dis assez
vite c'est c'est une demi-saison pour
pour commencer à avoir des choses dans
un contexte qui soit favorable et à
terme voilà c'est un joueur de je sais
plus quel âge il y aura 10-19
sur les 19
si on tient compte que c'est 9 10
derniers matchs avec avec les breakers
même si c'est pas la plus belle équipe
de du championnat australien on est
malgré tout sur sur un joueur qui a des
arguments pour lui dans la polyvalence
et sur plein d'autres aspects donc pas
forcément attendre quelque chose tout de
suite mais dans un contexte structurées
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas déconnant
alors l'avantage c'est quand même que
Cleveland est une équipe de la loterie
avec la base la plus la plus solide Manu
on peut l'imaginer jouer à côté de
Garland de meublé j'arrête Allen
Karis Lazer
tout à fait moi je suis
fan du potentiel je suis moins fan du
biscuits veulent l'atteindre c'est plus
ça mon souci avec lui mais je le vois
bien comme il a fait sur l'ANPE explosé
après le Starbuck quoi avoir un peu plus
de responsabilité tout dépend de la
saison des caves aussi mais si sur du
décembre janvier on les minutes sont là
et que
on voit des choses du 10 points cinq pas
ceux du 10.5 rebonds peut-être que ça va
aller de plus en plus et du coup avec la
rotation ça va ça va caler
si c'est le je pense le contexte qu'il
en n'est pas le pire honnêtement
là-dedans ils sont quoi ils sont 14 donc
moi
c'est l'une des équipes qui me convient
le mieux pour lui honnêtement parce que
je sais pas si on le met dans une autre
équipe qui est en pleine reconstruction
type Portland par exemple est-ce que il
réussirait est-ce que c'est un bon truc
pour lui le là c'est moi 14 qui me
convient 14 ou ouais dans ces eaux là 10
on profite parce qu'il y a tellement de
jeunes joueurs autour
ouais je voyais dommage je te voyais
grimacer
quand Manu évoquait le temps de jeu
probable pour toi Cleveland va vouloir
être trop complet enfin pas trop mais
trop compétitif pour bien pour que Diane
et du temps de jeu vite
honnêtement ouais ça m'inquiète un peu
pour plusieurs raisons déjà je comprends
totalement l'idée que les caves
sélectionnent bien parce que maintenant
la timeline la changer la timeline c'est
meublé c'est quand est-ce que movie va
pouvoir être le joueur dominant qui fera
le franchise player avec Garland en 3e
en deuxième option et Allen ou Sexton ou
au coross si le tiers se développe son
en 3e option donc la timeline a changé
et je pense que du coup on a le temps de
développer diangues donc là je rejoins
Manu ça marche bien c'est plus au niveau
de Jelly bicker staff en fait que j'ai
un souci c'est que c'est un coach qui a
une rotation assez serré même tout au
long de la saison régulière tant qu'on
n'avait pas 30 points d'avance on
gardait les 8 9 joueurs qui qui
bougeaient jamais
et
du coup la question c'est est-ce qu'il
va donner à diang l'opportunité de faire
des erreurs en fait
et là j'ai un doute donc je pense qu'il
passera pas mal de temps avec la Gillig
dans un sur une première partie de
saison
parce que les en plus elle est les caves
ont ramener l'équipe à Cleveland elle
était à Canton juste avant et maintenant
les dents qui vendent donc ça facilite
pas mal les les transactions les
allers-retours des joueurs mais ouais je
suis assez inquiet de si jamais ces
premières sorties sont pas convaincantes
des joueurs qu'on aurait pu aimer voir
se développer un peu plus comme Dylan
windler notamment
quel toujours pas descendu du wagon
tu rates tu as 10 minutes dans ton match
tu les rates pendant deux semaines tu
vois pas le terrain
alors que voilà moi c'est quelque chose
que on a demandé tout au long de l'année
sur le compte c'est quoi là on avait le
temps on avait l'opportunité de faire
jouer wingler par exemple parce qu'il a
apporté des choses en théorie et on
avait lu la place de le faire faire des
erreurs dans des matchs qui ont dominés
et en fait il l'a pas fait donc
qu'est-ce qui peut ça me rassure pas de
savoir qu'il aurait le développement
d'un Ding alors bon développement bon au
coraux c'est pas trop mal développé
garant de passer deux caps monumentaux
avec Big urtaff ln a bien progressé donc
le développement joueur je suis pas
inquiet c'est vraiment sur le développer
en faisant jouer et là là ça coin après
tu viens de NBA déjà jouer angélique
c'est le niveau du dessus
qui me conviendrait très bien j'adore
jaylan Williams parce qu'il fit vraiment
parfaitement dans tout ce qu'on veut
mais si Altman décide de partir sur le
plus gros potentiel bon là on imagine
dans trois quatre ans Franck
meublé Allen et ouais bon ça fait rêver
quoi si tout va si tout se passe bien
c'est bien
très bien on va conclure là dessus
romain avant que tu t'en ailles
je veux t'entendre sur la question
évidemment que tout le monde se pose qui
est le meilleur prospect de cette draft
selon toi
je te mets à la casserole c'est normal
est-ce que chez Tom graines est un pied
au dessus des autres est-ce que ça se
joue avec des semis des banques héros
des de Jaden
moi je suis pas fan de jabarisme ça
après j'arrive à désormais ça arrive à
des gens
c'est vrai qu'il y a que Manu de défend
corps et bien moi j'ai moi j'ai
énormément de mal
j'ai vu une statue de fois sur homegren
qui m'inquiète j'aime beaucoup le profil
j'ai vu le stade qui m'inquiète je suis
incapable de retrouver la source
qui disait que sur les joueurs
intérieurs drafté à moins de 90 kg aucun
avait tenu dans la ligue
il fait 89
peut-être que si bouffe un peu avant de
monter sur l'estrade il sera à 90
voilà donc c'est
j'ai envie j'ai envie de croire j'ai
envie de croire en graine comme à
l'époque des des gens ont cru en show de
Bradley pour d'autres raisons
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait banquero
j'ai du mal à décider entre les deux
pour moi le meilleur joueur de la draft
à terme alors meilleur prospect j'ai
plus de mal parce que
j'ai peut-être pas forcément assez lu
certains pour pour tout évaluer en
profondeur mais je dirais que sur le top
3 pour moi j'ai deux joueurs qui se
détachent et
[Musique]
peut vraiment devenir quelque chose de
très très intéressant
s'il n'y arrive pas je pense que que bon
queyraud peut être peut être peut être
une belle à une belle réussite
donc pour toi il y a un top 2 dans cette
drafts
il y a des choses qui me
il y a des choses dans latéralité dans
l'agressivité qui me gêne un petit peu
je serai plus à dire qu'il y a un top de
plus ok
à 3h du matin la nuit dernière
depuis 2010 seulement 4 joueurs drafté
en loterie ont eu un pourcentage de
réussite à deux points sous les 45%.
c'est le seul qui fait plus de 2 mètres
il faut dormir à la de temps en temps et
oui mais j'ai des fois je n'arrive pas
mais après bartorix c'est pas mal parce
que c'est avec camredish Zaïr Williams
et Michael Carter week-ends
Mathias c'est qui ton numéro 1 dans ton
barre de toi
moi j'ai un tiers 1 avec en graine et
banquero pareil mais j'ai une préférence
pour homme avec que les deux là donc
pareil toi tu dois peut-être Paris un
petit cran en dessous
OK et pour quelle raison pas pour pas
pour quelle raison que gabarit pour
quelle raison tu mets les deux autres au
dessus qu'est-ce qui comment tu comment
tu classes un petit peu en fait tes
prospects
c'est plus gabarit
Ivy que je mets en dessous
j'abaris pour son incapacité un peu à se
créer des points faciles quoi
même si il a longtemps été en bagarre
avec les deux autres mais j'ai
finalement descendu et puis j'ai déjà
Ivy que j'adore mais que je vois pas
j'ai du mal à voir en vrai gestionnaire
principal d'une équipe NBA
donc pour toi il bug ça se seront plus
des deuxièmes option tu les mets en
deuxième tiers
je pense pas que ce sera une première
option non plus mais ce qui va apporter
défensivement sera trop fort quoi
alors the fail dièse nous dit que chet a
refusé de donner son dossier médical
j'ai pas vu ça
donne moi ta source the fa dièse
théoriquement il en a pas donc
je rappelle quand même que Manu
t'as toujours déjà Paris premier Manu
quoi oui
est-ce que tu veux prendre sa défense
maintenant ou si tu veux qu'on fasse
autre chose
ça dépend de ton temps vas-y vas-y
et après comme ça on peut laisser partir
romain
moi je le défends et je pense que c'est
entre les dans mon tiens un avec chet et
je me le mets uniquement sur le
potentiel défensif et sur le shoot pour
moi il va défendre sur plusieurs
positions parce que chaque peut pas
faire ok
une Protector il y a pas de souci
là-dessus mais pour moi de gabarit Smith
peut défendre sur quasiment tout le
monde et ça bah c'est quasiment unique
dans cette draft il est capable de
shooter d'un peu partout excepté près du
cercle comme ça je suis pas inquiet avec
le spaceing NBA
et le gars fait de 10 quoi
je sais pas si on après je sais pas si
on se rend compte de du phénomène du
potentiel qui l'a mais
il y a clairement un manque de force sur
le premier pas clairement en manque de
handle pour justement aller au cercle
mais ça ça m'inquiète pas trop parce que
c'est pas forcément selon moi ce qu'on
va lui demander en premier de mettre des
tomates en dans le trafic en fait
pour moi ça force première c'est son
tiers donc
je suis d'accord si je trouve qu'il
prend beaucoup de choses forcés aussi
surtout à deux points
mais je suis pas je sais pas si ça c'est
des choses
mais pour moi ça se travaille ça se
passe pas trop compliqué à ça
sur lui c'est que c'est un gros bosseur
qui comprend le truc il a un papa ancien
je me rends le billet ou du moins juin
ancien joueur de basket donc
moi je suis pas inquiet là-dessus je
suis inquiet sur le handle je suis
inquiet sur certaines choses des petits
points mais c'est pas ce sur quoi je
fais lui demander d'être bon donc en soi
je m'en fiche un peu
il va voir travailler c'est pas le souci
mais
pas ce qui m'inquiète le plus tellement
persuadé qu'il va être bon défensivement
et sur le tir que
ce que peut pas faire en grain par
exemple même si il y a une graine est
très fort au tire très fort au
protection mais il va pas pouvoir aller
prendre du lit quoi
sa mission gabarit jouait avec Kessler
qui lui prenait les rebonds et protéger
le cercle donc c'est aussi différent
donc
là il jouera
il est au Magic
donc potentiellement c'est jouer avec
mon Bamba ou undel Carter qui eux
prendront les rebonds aussi c'est pas
forcément son truc donc
il y a ça mais il y a le fait aussi
qu'on était au burn tu sais que tu as
quelqu'un derrière toi donc finalement
quand tu trouves défensivement on
devrait moins
aussi toi tu as des questions sur la
défense comment pour finir là-dessus
pour finir sur le chemin
latéralité me
latéralité mais c'est un peu perplexe il
y a deux choses
[Musique]
voilà les idées petites choses un peu un
peu bizarres qui me qui me questionne le
fait que la latérité soit pas trop là et
puis encore une fois ta question
derrière donc
en ayant question derrière c'est j'ai
envie de te dire c'est pas plus facile
de les vendre mais je peux faire plus de
bêtises
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais il faudra
voir le rôle dans lequel il sera utilisé
évidemment absolument NBA puisque selon
l'équipe qui le drame on va peut-être
pas projeter les mêmes choses pour
Jabari Smith merci Romain
ça commence à quelle heure la draft sur
bein tu sais ou quoi 1h55 et il vous
file les pizzas ou au moins même pas on
a on a ce qu'il faut mais c'est caché
dans le décor ça fait partie des petits
des petites choses qu'on c'est la télé
on dévoile pas c'est un peu le mystère
du ministère de dire et des choses
cachées dans le décor
on se retrouve turbine sport avec
l'immense Rémi Reverchon pour la soirée
draft et avec
votre sud et pressing
Mathias est-ce que tu as une autre take
est-ce que tu as des questions aussi que
tu voulais partager avec nous
ou alors j'avais une petite question
est-ce que vous pensez bon évidemment
dans une grave tout est possible mais
est-ce que pour vous il y a une vraie
possibilité que Edge Griffin ne soit pas
drafté en loterie à cause de son dossier
médical
moi j'en sais rien mais
l'histoire dit que oui quand même
il y a des prospects qu'on dit c'est
quoi
pourquoi vous l'avez mis 11 moi je l'ai
mis 11 parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il
est plus dans le deuxième groupe que
dans le premier groupe top 5 ou 2e
groupe du vaccin qui a 12 13
je l'ai mis 11 plus parce que je
trouvais qu'il allait bien au X
ont pas été pris en Autriche alors je
compare pas mais il y avait des dossiers
médicaux
avancer sur les deux donc c'est possible
dans ce n'est pas fait les mêmes saisons
que Griffin mais ça arrive à l'inverse
porter en loterie
on est pris en loterie aussi
est-ce que est-ce que on regarderait pas
quand même cette histoire de notre draft
que je vous ai écrite
et comme ça vous me dites si c'est bien
si c'est pas bien
si vous votez pour si vous votez compte
alors en 1 je vais l'afficher en partage
d'écran mais en un j'avais
cheatham graine au Magic
qu'en pensez-vous
à pire on a vu plus grande calomnie
et j'avais ah oui le Magic choisissait
un grain Christiane Coloco et Hugo
Besson
justification ah oui non un mot quand
même sur un potentiel duo puisque ce que
je mettais en avant seul
je trouve que c'est formidable
et je trouve que vraiment lampe
bénéficier de l'autre ils ont vraiment
des faiblesses
qui sont couvertes par les qualités de
l'objet
si on pense que le meilleur joueur le
prendre un ça a du sens début du
deuxième tour tu prends un spécialiste
du tir et physique la pire quelque chose
en deux
vous pouvez intervenir à tout moment en
merci Lucio ça valide
Oklahoma City choisi Jabari Smith j'ai
pas mis Paolo banquero pour des
questions de
besoin d'avoir la balle
Jabari
Williams
donc plutôt du polyvalent
défensivement
et plutôt du mec qui tire sauf j'ai du
Williams mais peut-être qu'il tirera
franchement dans même pas parce qu'ils
sont vraiment fournis il y a très mal
qui sort du banc et
[Musique]
en vrai moi c'est plus j'abaris en deux
qui me dérange mais Murray Williams ça
fait du sens calme
je pense pas
sur ce que je ferais moi mais sur voilà
mariage idéal un peu scénario idéal pour
un peu pour la franchise un peu pour le
prospect voilà qui vient de Murray à
hauteur ça permet ça lui permet de pas
avoir un poids trop lourd sur les
épaules offensivement d'arriver dans une
équipe qui est quand même déjà un peu
compétitive avec guindus avec Alexander
qui
tout de suite va continuer à driver mais
aurait pu lui poser des écransmises peut
lui poser des écrans ils peuvent aussi
tous les deux shooter dans les coins
clairement
qu'est-ce que tu
qu'est-ce que tu penses de Kendall Brown
c'est un joueur qui fait débat chez nous
j'aime bien je l'avais très haut au
début bon je l'ai un petit peu descendu
mais j'aime beaucoup c'est un joueur qui
pourra s'intégrer très facilement dans
une n'importe quelle équipe je vois bien
dans une équipe contender après je vois
que
US il a pas la super cote je l'ai vu bas
hein
carrément je trouve ça bizarre
en tout cas si une équipe là au deuxième
tour je pense que ça peut être un beau
petit style quand même
de tir quoi mais effectivement
physiquement c'est un des prospects les
plus impressionnants de la cuvée
qu'est-ce que j'ai mis comme comme
bêtise oui il y a pas grand monde qui
descend quand même qui était de
mais dans un tiers qui commence en 17 18
donc clairement c'est c'est le règne où
je le prendrai vraiment
je me dis qu'ils ont le temps de le
développer quoi il y a des équipes moins
de temps et que du coup vont en faire un
gars
en fait ce qui serait dommage ça serait
d'en faire un gars qui fait juste du
screen and roll quoi
manu a dit qu'il revenais alors on
reprendra le fil plus tard on accueille
nouvelle invité j'ai pas ton prénom
Nanny tu peux m'appeler Robin
qui toi aussi vous vous allez faire la
draft ensemble non les amis
qui est azk et aussi du coup Mathias
c'est de faire ça on space
tranquillement on va déprivé tout ça
[Musique]
qui alors on discutait du First speed
tout à l'heure toi tu as qui en fait moi
j'ai en graine je sais que c'est je
pense pas que c'est un consensus mais
chez nous ce n'est pas presse mais en
tout cas la moyenne en plus je pense que
pour le Magic c'est c'est le plus haut
parfait on a de la discuté en plus en
space c'était que je pense qu'en plus
John allemande de fans de genre de
profil donc pour moi il y a pas de il y
a pas beaucoup de questions à se poser
maintenant
est-ce que tu as une haute take
je sais pas si c'était
alors de ce que on a eu comme info du
coup moi je serais qu'avec shahim on a
vu que bref mcgowens apparemment a fait
des très bons workout avec les Hawks
donc ce serait que Brest mcgowells
et que ce serait un petit peu le la
surprise la draft
mais c'est très bien comme ça parce que
Manu saotech c'était Brightman Gohan
vous allez être elle dit quoi une
légende un toutouet de légende
[Musique]
ce sera
et il y avait une question sur le chat
quel est le premier joueur or green Room
qui va être racheté dans ce cas là ça
pourrait du coup être Mac Cohen si s'il
est en 16 Hawks c'est un monde qui
existe pas mal pas mal toi tu en penses
quoi de Brice mcdows est-ce que tu
penses qu'il mérite une sélection aussi
moi pardon oui à toi
franchement j'aime beaucoup je trouve
que Nebraska en plus le coach frederg je
passe au plus grand fan et je trouve que
en termes de niveau shooting je trouve
qu'il est un peu sous-estimer les
chiffres reprend pas forcément sa
qualité je vous fais une bonne qualité
de shoot il a des épaules il me rappelle
un peu de gens tellement Ray dans la
frame je trouve qu'il joue très bien les
épaules et très bien son physique et en
plus je trouve qu'à côté de triangle il
faut je pense à ce joueur en plus qui
peut jouer à Ball qui va amener de la
défense du roman dure sur l'homme et ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il qui l'expose un
peu comme ça parce qu'en plus il a une
belle envergure synthétique je pense que
c'est un profil qui qui fit en fait
parfaitement pour les pour les autres
qui ont besoin de défense extérieur
quand tu sais que ta Bogdanovitch tu as
aussi heurter tu as besoin de ce jeu un
peu plus
slasher si je veux dire et accès à ses
défenses qui va libérer le Trion en fait
en défense
plutôt d'accord avec toi sur ce dont on
a besoin les Hobbes d'ailleurs dans ma
note alors moi je leur ai mis bien mais
je leur ai mon argument c'était le même
Staz ils ont besoin d'un autre créateur
malgré tout l'amour que j'ai pour Kevin
Marter
en fait en playoffre quand en triangle
est bien pris c'est Kevin warter qui se
retrouve à devoir créer des tirs après
après en degré de la longue distance le
truc comme ça
c'est un peu efficace mais pas très
efficace qui vont voir
donc voilà Brice mcgowens Alan
franchement j'aime beaucoup je pense
surtout qu'il faut comme la fait Manu il
faut voir dans un autre contexte parce
que on lui demandait d'être le gotag de
prendre beaucoup de tirs d'être la
menace offensive numéro une année brosse
casse qui a fait baisser son efficacité
sauf sur la fin d'année où ça allait
mieux d'ailleurs il aurait dû commettre
à Florida State à la base il était
commutateur il a été un Nebraska avec
son frère
ça aurait été vraiment ça je sais pas si
il a bien fait en tout cas c'est plus
exposé c'est ce qu'il voulait c'est
c'est ce qu'on a pu voir mais c'est vrai
que talent offensif la longueur qu'il a
il a plus de 10 ans virgule quasiment 2
m c'est un vrai athlète j'achète le tir
aussi parce que il a pris beaucoup de
tirs forcés mais je pense que c'est un
meilleur tireur que les que les chiffres
ne le montent cette année donc ouais moi
je pense que
c'est un vrai bon prospect sur lequel
parier dans la deuxième partie du
premier tour qui peut vraiment qui n'a
vraiment pas pu montrer ce qu'il pouvait
tout ce qui pouvait aller Braska et dont
le premier statistique comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure on parle pas du tout
hommage aux joueurs que c'est
allez messieurs on est sur la fin de ce
live on va pas on va pas dérouler toute
la mode draft
parce que ça va être un peu long mais
on a fait le top 3 déjà est-ce que vous
avez envie de rendre hommage à un joueur
qui va être le second tour et personne
ne connaîtra le nom mais si vous le
dites ce soir et ben comme pour Manu
avec Brice mcgowens je pourrais Clipper
ça et le poster en disant
Robin l'avait dit mathiaste avait dit ce
qui est un joueur du second tour qui
vous qui vous plaît que vous voyez avoir
un rôle et aussi expliquez-moi pourquoi
qui pour moi sera un bon role player NBA
ce qui défend bien il polyvalent et qui
saute il shootent bien quoi alors et
c'est pas le meilleur athlète mais c'est
un compétiteur très intelligent qu'un
très bon environnement familial et je
pense que il a tout ce qu'il faut pour
durer une bière
il a son père qui fait sa pub
ça meneur des boules
je vous le rappelle ou peut-être aux
personnes qui nous écoutent qui nous
regardent ils jouaient où au quel âge il
jouait à rudget dans une petite équipe
d'une belle conférence qui l'a emmené
deux années d'affilée en mars Madness
qui alors qu'ils avaient pas été
qualifiés depuis très longtemps et c'est
un senior il doit avoir 22 ans je pense
je dis pas de bêtises
c'est ça
Robin est-ce que tu as donc Ron Harper
junior on retient dans un rôle de
fluendis si j'ai bien compris ce que tu
disais
il faut pour moi il lui faut de 10
ligues il lui faut en fait de
l'expérience pour l'instant il a il est
il faut simplement qu'ils jouent
mais il y a un risque effectivement ça
peut être un buzz mais je trouve qu'il a
vraiment un obstacle assez haut et que
au deuxième tour on peut prendre le
risque en fait de se tromper si je veux
dire
Watson c'est un peu tricher mais non je
pense qu'il va dire aussi mais c'est
vrai que longtemps eu Alan tu as
toujours le top 30
quasiment je crois 30 ou 31
ça peut marcher dans un rôle à la brume
qui arrive Paston
il faut vraiment qu'il soit drafté par
les équipes qui le veulent quoi
le même chouchou que toi mon chat
pour me rendre hommage la dernière
c'était George primo donc
ça va mais tu t'attends pas l'autre je
pense je l'avais en fait j'avais fait un
article pour les requêtes c'est pour moi
c'était le choix parfait en 25 un joueur
jaune et le fait qu'il tombe au sperme
que je surpris mais je suis super
content et je trouve qu'il a fait une
fin de saison quand même qui est un
passé un peu sous le radars et que je
pense que prochaine saison on va on va
passer surpris
[Musique]
qui peut prendre feu un peu Dior Smith
mais je crois beaucoup en son tir
notamment très bon défenseur polyvalent
mais je crois beaucoup en soutien et la
shooté qu'à
31%. mais fresh panne et Michigan State
donc pas forcément le coach qui laisse
le plus de place en fraîchement dans son
jeu ouais ouais je sais bien quoi
il avait pas forcément beaucoup le
ballon quoi je sais pas c'est autour
merci
alors dans le chat on a décidé de remuer
les couteaux dans les plaies profondes
qui sont dans mon corps repos père
cashing ne sera sans doute jamais un
joueur américain il change de club en
tout cas on a déjà dit ça l'année
dernière alors j'attends qu'il a raison
c'est pour ça
la question
fort du réel il s'en va sombres en
Belgique
un gaucher soyeux
si je voulais vraiment vraiment aller
loin je dirais fanbozeng mais je vais
parce que je crois vraiment à fan de
mon top 60 ça ne vaut évidemment
très fort chinois
je pense vraiment qu'il a un futur mais
honnêtement il y a un vrai bras
pour la blague
aura une meilleure carrière que Marjane
boatchen à la mode
incroyable sinon
j'avais Christian Braun mais je crois
que c'est un peu triché parce qu'il
pense qu'il va peut-être être un peu
trop
il est en 25 et 40 donc je dirais
jammari Bouya San Francisco
ça peut être un backup meneur NBA je
pense
à deux points en carrière 34% à 3 points
beaucoup de couleurs il y a 2 mètres
d'envergure pour un 87 donc
si c'est vraiment paris paris toulay je
peux le tenter et puis il peut être une
vie plus de Summer League à tout le
monde
parce que les joueurs d'un 87 c'est
qu'il faut qu'il soit épais pour tenir
franchement ça va c'est moins pire que
ce que je pensais c'est moins pire que
ce que je pensais et en bonus mais
vraiment non Marcus bingame junior
Michigan State parce qu'il a un corps
incroyable et donc de 10 de 25 dents
virgule comment ça peut attirer il a
fait des workouts avec Boston Toronto
d'autres aussi il y a un monde où ça
peut devenir crise bouchée donc on verra
mais il y a un monde aussi où dans
quatre ans il est en demi-finale de
relig titulaire
voilà
si vous avez d'autres questions dans le
chat c'est le moment sinon je vais
fermer la boutique merci
[Rires]
on vous donne rendez-vous vous êtes
encore 84 vous êtes fous deux heures de
live on vous donne rendez-vous
[Musique]
on sera sur twitch nous
c'est envergure avant la prise d'antenne
en fait on va faire moi j'y connais rien
en twitch mais on va faire un team
il y aura deux collaboration
ensuite sur Steam va prendre le lead
évidemment avec Manu et Alan aux
analyses on va certes je sais pas
jusqu'où ils vont aller parce qu'ils
sont fatigués ils commencent les trois
croix en ce moment mais
allez je pense jusqu'à
Ousmane Diagne ou jusqu'à la fin de la
loterie
et à la suite de ça on reprendra et on
vous fera toute la fin du premier tour
evidemment pendant ce temps-là vous
pouvez mettre la télé pour essayer de
regarder quand romain à la parole pour
avoir sa son analyse également
puisqu'il y a toutes les toutes les
notes
il arrive à la fin
sera peut-être là en tout cas pour le
twitch on espère
on aura tous les experts de notre de
notre data team qui seront disponibles
aussi et puis sur les réseaux sociaux on
va vous faire vivre ça avec
tous les choix soit par choix sur
Twitter sur Instagram etc comme
d'habitude donc voilà on n'a pas parlé
de Diaries pour une fois dieu merci
dans ma mobdrap je l'avais Warriors et
je trouve que c'est une super idée
bonne soirée Jo danielos bonne soirée
bonne soirée Mathias bonne soirée Robin
Hannut